نحن نعلم أن الذئاب لا تجلس حولها
تعوي طوال اليوم ولكن ما الذي تفعله الذئاب
بالإضافة إلى صد الدببة السوداء
لحماية أشبالها الآن بفضل
كاميرا طوق الذئب ،
حصلنا على نظرة عين الذئب الباحثين في
حديقة voyageurs الوطنية في مينيسوتا
قاموا بتثبيت طوق كام  الذئب الوحيد
الذي حوصروه وقاموا بتخديره
وذهب بعيدًا ، كان أهم ما يميزنا
هو
مشاهدة الذئب الذي يصطاد الذئاب
أثناء صيد الأسماك بالكاميرا ، لكن مشاهدة
سمكة واحدة
من وجهة نظره وهي تصطاد العديد من
مصاصي التفريخ كان أمرًا مثيرًا
للباحثين.
ذئب يمضغ على عظمة ساق غزال ،
قام مشروع الذئب المسافر بتعقب هذا
الشاب لمدة ستة
أسابيع يشاهده وهو يشاهد الغربان في
السماء ، وقد صنعت طوق الكاميرا من قبل شركة
ألمانية حتى أنها تجعلها
كبيرة جدًا بالنسبة للأفيال
، حيث كانت كاميرا الذئب  تمت برمجته للانفصال
عن بوابة محددة ونظام تحديد المواقع العالمي (GPS) مكن
الباحثين من استعادته ،
ما هو معلومة الكرة الغريبة المفضلة لتوم
جابل حول السر
تأكل حياة الذئاب في منطقتنا الكثير من العنب البري ،
ليس فقط لأنها تأكلها ، بل
إنها تقذفها أحيانًا
حتى يأكل أشبالها ،
تحدث عن إعادة تدوير كاميرا الذئب التي
استحوذت على الكثير من النوم
وكانت الأشياء مشعرة باستمرار سواء كانت
جافة أو تقطر
مبللة بالعدسة  كانت مغطاة بالشعر كما
لاحظ أحد المشاهدين
أنني أشعر بأنني قريب جدًا من هذا الذئب ، فأنا أحب
السوشي
، فأنا أجري في الغابة وتحتاج لحيتي إلى
تقليم
وهو ما يخطط الباحثون للقيام به
في المرة القادمة التي يستخدمون فيها طوق الذئب
كام  من المحتمل أن أقوم بقص
هذا الشعر الذي
يبقي كفوفك بعيدًا عن معطفي. قصة شعر
كافية لتكوين ذئب وحيد.
كيف الجني
[موسيقى]
cnn